glad everybody managed to find the room
after we were all
misinformed and I'm opening the hearing
on House Bill 1188 and call
Representative
BR thank you chair Maguire House Bill
1188 was um is being presented to the
committee as a means of removing some of
the barriers that lnas have when they're
entering the
workforce in the current statutes LNA is
included in those profession s that have
aprns RNs and licensed practicing nurses
to have the ability to read and write
the English
language and although um these individ
these individuals who have a degree have
passed a test in English and have taken
a have taken um the courses in English
they may not have what we will call the
ability to read and write in the English
language so we have taken them out of
this
requirement and in section
two it uh does require them
to uh have a license and to have enough
of an English aptitude in English
language as defined in rules and to have
a criminal background check and
um essentially put guard veils on those
individuals who are applying for that
license um the only thing that I noticed
um when when I looked at this last night
was that um it does submit an
application in fees established by the
board and that should be the office so
we need a small Amendment for that um
other than that I hope that you'll
support the bill if you have any
questions I'll be glad
to representative leus yeah just uh
we've been in other uh subcommittees on
other bills instead of by the board been
using the executive director because our
understanding is it should be a
person that's my suggestion for the
amendment well I'll take a look at that
levely amended amendment that I
presented to everyone on Friday and make
sure that
it's uh they all work together how's
that y thank
you thank you one other thing is just a
moment is that the licensing
subcommittee worked on LNA requirements
and if they and they took that change
out of the bill so if there are any
other changes this would be the
appropriate place to incorporate them
yep I'll speak with representative leus
about that okay yes one Amendment would
be easier all right represent Manti
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question to
part that what we worked on the
subcommittee where the consistency of
the work office or executive director
and also how we combined
LNA under that clears up a lot more
confusion for me to look at it so that
would be fantastic thank you okay yep
okay any other
questions thank you very much thank you
Kier Dutton or Carrie
Dutton hi my name is Carrie Dutton I'm
the owner and operator of LNA health
careers we're the largest LNA training
school in New Hampshire we a privately
run postsecondary trade school and we
graduate about 1,000 to 1200 lnas per
year and because of the current RSA we
turn
away on average 200 to maybe 400
individuals each year because they
cannot pass the standardized English
test and write an essay that would
demonstrate their ability to read and
write in
English um these workers want to be
caregivers they're new Americans they're
not yet at the proficiency level but we
often lose these individuals after
sending them away to ESL classes and I
just think we would be better prepared
to care for our elderly in New Hampshire
and those who need care if we welcome
them into uh the workforce
thank you represent M thank you madam
chair so these individuals they are
postsecondary um does that always J with
10 + 2 or is it 10 is the uh K through
10 some countries have that so do you
make that
distinction sorry we do not at the our
trade school level um but the high
schools the CTE programs are highly
affected by this RSA they have programs
for new Americans and they can't welcome
them into the programs for LNA training
because of the English language
proficiency
issue thank you I'm a bit
concerned what level of English would
these people have because I would hope
they'd be able to understand the nurses
or other people's uh
orders and also communicate with the
patients one thing about nursing in
medical terminology is it's a whole
different language than English itself
and so we would train the individuals to
do that and many times the few that do
make it back to us without going to
other entry-level jobs we're teaching
them although you learned English
there's this whole other language that
we're teaching you to enter the um
healthare
Workforce ah thank you that's good to
know any other questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well you
already touched on the issue that I
wanted to uh raise and that is uh the
the the I'm especially concerned about
the situation with
patients um who in many cases are going
to be elderly and and if if they are in
distress in any way especially and they
have somebody that that they communicate
their needs to who can't understand
English it's it's not only that they
they're not going to get their needs met
but they may have a a panic uh reaction
uh or um or something similar that will
make their situation worse than it was
uh when they needed something
besides understanding uh so um I I I
certainly can understand that it perhaps
you have an individual that's
hypothesized uh who speaks
Spanish uh and the patient speaks
Spanish well then they don't have to
Converse in English uh but if they speak
Spanish and the person is Vietnamese or
vice versa uh that's even worse uh so uh
how can changing the statute help I
understand that there are certain
technical terms but my understanding is
that lnas are largely doing non-medical
stuff uh as a matter of fact I think
they're not competent in many cases to
do medical things although they may
they're doing absolutely valid um and
important necessary functions such as
cleaning up messy situations not a
pleasant situation but it's got to be
done and and it needs to be done uh um
so again a foreign language can be very
helpful if you've got the patient
speaking that language so uh but but
English I I I think is absolutely
essential so how can dispensing with a
requirement for English skills uh
Advance our
cause yes thank you uh representative
schmith that's an important question and
all lnas would still resp be responsible
to meet the qualifications to take the
state exam and pass every LNA program
has a clinical portion with a skills
checklist to ensure that they understand
the most important words such as toilet
bathroom um walking call my family all
those things would still be included and
be required so it's not that they would
be only fluent in Spanish per se and go
work at conquered hospital they would
still need to know the important words
that their patient would be asking for
or requesting Services of it's also
important to know that um you know
roughly 75% of the individuals in LNA
would be caring for may not be
communicative so lnas do spend a lot of
time learning about anticipating needs
body language facial expressions and for
non-communicative um patients there are
often um pictures that patients can
point to to express their needs and we
as the educator would be making sure
that they are able to U perform all the
tasks required and communicate
effectively with their patients before
letting them take the state exam
followup thank you um mam chair and
thank you uh so what you've said is
helpful and for my understanding of the
situation but I I uh uh I happen to be a
linguist uh and I can uh read uh I don't
know at least to some degree in eight or
10 languages okay um and and in the
course of ordinary business I get bills
and so forth for example from uh Mass
General they're they they send a page
that has statement in English at the top
but it also has the same or equivalent
statement in 10 or 15 languages saying
if you need a a translator uh please
apply you're en tile one and so forth
and so on um and I I practice on my
other languages or new languages I'm
working with uh trying to
read uh some language I that I'm not
very good at uh but the thing is do you
have something like that so the person
can look and see and find their own
language and at least say that that so
you know what language they're speaking
uh and because I'm sure that occurs that
you have people from a country country
that we haven't been discussing at this
point that you might have several
patients from that family so how do you
deal with
that you don't have to hold that you
know you turn it on and leave it on St
thank you very helpful thank you um so
right now we don't have tools like that
because the students are expected to be
able to read and write and speak fluent
English but we would love to incorporate
tools like that employer ERS may have
tools like that if they're hiring people
who need additional help if this is
approved I I'm concerned about primarily
about the patients because those are the
people who are in need uh and and and
very often elderly uh and they may not
have you know good communicating ability
not because of uh the the language that
they're that they're ex uh that they're
native to uh but because because they
are elderly and Confused uh and you you
you uh how do you how do you deal with
those people because they are your
primary
concern y that's the issue I have yeah I
think if whoever is responsible for that
individual in hiring the caregiver would
be responsible to have those additional
tools if they choose to hire someone
they don't feel is capable or at the
level to care for their patient
population um but I would ensure that
every LNA who graduated from my school
was prepared and ready to pass the state
exam and be Workforce ready with the
skills
required I would imag I would imagine
that the employer knows how many con
nonverbal or non-english speakers they
have in their their patient population
yes representative Brown and then man py
uh thank you madam chair um following up
on both those questions so on line
16 one of the new requirements is have
suff aptitude in the English language as
defined in the rules
adopted I'm guessing that would be oplc
writing those rules suggesting those
rules um so I don't know if you have a
feel for what sufficient aptitude might
mean So currently sufficient aptitude is
the student has to write an essay that
is in proper grammar that we can read
and is legible um and we give a
standardized test test um it's an ESL
test and we grade so we require an 80%
or better um and that's what the Board
of Nursing has approved for the old PLC
um but I think it's too high of a
standard I think we're leaving out a lot
of individuals that could be great
caregivers thank you and follow up you I
think you answer what I was going to ask
so we're at the sufficient aptitude
level now so if it says this in here
does that change where we are in your as
far as you're
concerned I think yes I think it should
be
changed so if follow up again sorry
madam
chair if I'm understanding you it says
sufficient aptitude in the in the bill
and that's where we are right now and
you think maybe it should not say
sufficient aptitude in the
bill no it's right now the rules
specify the law says they must have
ability to read and write that's the
same as a as a licensed nurse so this
says they have sufficient aptitude which
would probably be a lesser standard well
that's
yeah okay thank you representative Mani
thank you madam chair uh question when
you have the LNA training uh not only
language medical terminology do you also
have cultural sensitivity and uh
awareness um diversity and cultural
sensitivity yes okay we do how follow up
Madam chair follow up how does that
impact being able to assess the cultural
a patient as well as the caregiver to
match does that give you an opportunity
to do that it does very much so so we're
able to teach about other cultures um
teach our students to be more inclusive
understanding we introduce them to
different cultures religions um
preferences
um thank you followup uh now with the
Aging
population uh in New Hampshire do you
see diversity in clientele or the
patients to not everybody's english-
speaking exactly yes we have a many many
um health care providers who the elderly
are optioning to stay home versus going
to a Center for Nursing Care and um
there's a very large population of many
different diverse cultures right now
in representative Dolan thank you madam
chair in the uh situation as you're
training
lpas and you find uh if this law were to
be changed and you find that they don't
have very good English or or um
communication skills along those lines
what do you teach
them uh to overcome that if they find
themselves in a situation where they
can't adequately communicate with their
patients what what do you what do you
what do they do and what do you teach
them to do yeah so this would open up
avenues for me to be able to have
additional um English training classes
whereas now my hands are kind of tied I
can't I really shouldn't be admitting
anyone to my school unless they're
proficient and meet the standard that
the RSA says but now I will be able to
do that I could maybe even advertise in
another language to attract those
beginning speakers and then further
development um their skills so that they
can pass the state test and meet the
standardized threshold for them to enter
the workforce thank you okay other
questions representative Simon
thank you madam chair so uh you keep
mentioning that they'll have to pass the
standardized test I'm assuming that the
standardized test is in English yes it
is okay so they'll have to be proficient
enough in the language to pass the
examination one way or the other correct
thank
you other questions thank you very
much director
Courtney good morning Madam chair
members of the committee lindsy Courtney
executive director
oplc um wish to thank representative
Gera for bringing this forward we fully
support the bill um nursing is very
unique in the sense that um other
healthc care professions other
professions that we license do not
require um one demonstrate the ability
to re and write in the Lang in the
English language in order to get a
license may be required to actually
practice your profession may be required
by your employer but it's not required
for lure purposes it is required um in
nursing um and I think the challenge is
that the test that folks have to pass um
represents a higher level English as you
as as you will um then you would
necessarily need in order to actually
practice your profession it's an it's
unethical for you to be able to provide
services to a patient that you can't
communicate with in any capacity um and
I think the statute really is
presumptuous and assumes that all of the
patients are going to be English
speakers which we know with the changing
demographics in New Hampshire that's not
always the case um if your patient
speaks Spanish and you don't have the
ability to communicate either in the
written or cues clearly you're not um be
you're not able to provide services to
that patient to those patients so this
um I think it's a pretty uh minor change
it allows the Board of Nursing some Flex
ability to still ensure that the lnas
have to be able to converse with the
patient in English but it does modify
the standards or give the board a little
bit flexibility to modify the standards
um to not uh require that they pass a
strict English uh written and um verbal
test and for that we fully support it um
I just want to note again Physicians we
bring them in from other countries they
don't have to take such a test um
dentists they don't have to take such a
test Allied Health they don't have to
take such a test uh nursing does so um
that's just something for you to keep in
mind and I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you
representative
gold so if I understand this uh thank
you madam Shar and thank you for taking
my question if I understand this
correctly what we're saying is that by
not putting that we're giving the
flexibility the nursing board will
decide what the proficiency level is and
that will be handled in rule as opposed
to be in statutory Authority the exact
amount of proficiency and it gives some
flexibility to make changes without this
committee having to go through the
legislative process is that right yes
and I think that's important
particularly with the changing
demographics that we see um among
patients um to give the board the
board's a little uncomfortable I think
um but I I think giving them that
flexibility is important as opposed to
having it set in
statute
okay thank you represent Mani thank you
madam chair um the other professions
that do not require this do they have to
take TOEFL which is the the op foreign
language English language proficiency
test for foreign graduates we have to
take that in order
to get lenser or get into the profession
does that have anything to do with the
nursing if uh nursing has that so
nursing does have they do accept the
TOEFL RN LPNs um there's another
examination I believe that they accept
if um you have somebody coming in that's
foreign educated um and applying to
other medical schools it's possible that
the that the residencies or other
programs would require the TOEFL or
something comparable from a lure
standpoint we don't require
that and I think that represents the
distinction between employment and lure
lure is supposed to represent the
minimum competency can you perform their
profession in order to perform it
ethically you have to be able to
communicate with your patient but the
patient may not speak English so um you
know is it an employment issue or is it
a lure issue
interesting question Simon thank you
madam chair uh and thank you for taking
my question and I appreciate uh
everything that you're saying about the
lure component of it just um trying to
finish wrapping my head around the um
State examination that's going to be
passed where they'll have to be able to
speak the language or understand the
language well enough to pass the exam
but then we're we're saying that there's
a lower standard that they should be
able to achieve in the language in order
to gain
lure what's the differentiation
like how can they read and pass the exam
if they're not also able to write a
short paragraph in the language it like
where where does that line kind of fall
I think that's question I do I think
that's something we're going to have to
work out in rules I think it's unclear
at this point in time um and I was
actually surprised to hear about the
essay because I think a large majority
of our high school students who are
native English speakers probably
couldn't wrate an essay with proper for
grammar um so I think that speaks though
to the concern is are we are the
requirements um too strict you know do
you need to write in perfect grammar um
in order to be able to provide competent
care to your patient um I think that's
something sorry representative but I
think that's something that would have
to be worked out in roles with
stakeholders all right followup followup
thank you uh yeah so just for
clarification you don't you don't know
that line at this point when the bill is
being presented no okay no thank
you
okay all right I I think that part of it
is that even if you grow up speaking
another language in this country your
vocabulary is not going to be as broad
as it would be if you were you know
reading serious books and so forth and
and even if some someone speaks both
Lang two two or more languages they
might need to uh get a refresher in
medical English or
whatever okay anyone
else thank you for your time okay is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
1188 seeing none I will close the public
hearing representative groto will be
working on a an
amendment and
we are off until 11:30 thank
you all
[Music]
right yeah my friend called it kitchen
with
um I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
1190 and I call the prime sponsor
representative
Shapiro who will give us a pink card
when he gets a chance and doesn't need
to read his
testimony Madam chair and committee
members thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak in favor of House
Bill 1190 which will have us adopt the
interstate social work licensure compact
as a career social worker
with close to 50 years in the field I'm
honored to bring this this important
bill to you
today if passed and signed into law New
Hampshire will join the newly formed
compact which will allow social workers
from
any of the compact states to practice in
any of the other compact States
enhancing the portability of licensed
professionals improving continuity of
care when clients travel or
relocate and strengthening our Workforce
in the mental health Arena as well as in
many other practice areas where worker
shortages are at crisis
levels the compact has been developed by
the Council of state
governments The Association of Social
Work boards and the Department of
Defense it should be noted that the that
occupational interstate compacts are
particularly important to military
families who move frequently they
provide continuity of medical care and
fluid opportunities for spouses to
obtain employment in a new
state
being new this compact will only go into
effect when identical language is
adopted by seven states thus far two
states have
adopted the compact language Missouri
and South Dakota currently legislation
is pending in 27 other States including
New Hampshire Maine and
Vermont joining early means that we will
have the opportunity to be part of
developing the rules which will Reg
ulate these multi-state
licenses currently New Hampshire is a
member of interstate compacts allowing
New Hampshire audiologists physical
therapists occupational therapists
nurses doctors psychologists and
licensed Mental Health Counselors to
practice in other states and vice
versa while social workers are critical
to our mental health Workforce well over
half of the mental health licenses in
New Hampshire are social workers it is
important to note that social workers
practice in many areas including
education Child Protection medical
Corrections developmental disabilities
policy development and
advocacy I do not think I need to tell
the members of this committee about the
workforce shortages we face in all these
areas I sit on the board of one of our
community mental health centers and
every month we are confronted with
vacant positions High turnover rates
limited client access and and stories
about Cutthroat competition to fill
positions I certainly do not expect that
joining the social work compact will in
itself resolve our Workforce shortage
areas in the area of mental health and I
know this committee and oplc has already
made some important recent changes to
enhance portability of
lure the compact is one more tool that
will ease the burden of client cents and
professionals receiving and providing
Services across state
lines I first became interested in this
issue after being contacted by a large
private nonprofit counseling counseling
agency in Kean where I live the director
recounted many situations where they
would make a hire either from far or
near we we're very close to the Vermont
border only to have the expected
employment languish for month after
month as the clinician attempted to get
licensed in New Hampshire often giving
up along the
way I want to address two questions that
people have brought to my attention as
I've talked to people about this bill
first will joining the compact in any
way less than the quality of Eligibility
criteria for social workers practicing
in New
Hampshire will it will
it will it lessen the quality of the
social workers practice here basically I
believe the answer is no a compact
clinical social worker will need a
degree from an accredited MSW program
pass passage of a national qualifying
exam and two years post-graduate
supervised
experience the equivalent criteria for a
New Hampshire license and the equivalent
um criteria when I got my license um
many many years
ago second question once we have joined
what do we do if we disagree with the
regulatory language or are otherwise
dissatisfied with the governance or
functioning of the
compact just as we can pass this bill to
adopt the compact we can at any time
pass legislation to end our involvement
in fact in 2021 we did just that passing
SB 133 to repeal participation in the
emergency medical technician
compact in summary I would ask you to
vote in favor of this important
animportant Common Sense approach to
enhancing reciprocity and reducing the
regulatory burden on those who provide
critical services to the citizens of New
Hampshire thank you thank you are there
questions representative
manip thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
how
many let me phrase it in a way that I
can ask um you mentioned there are
certain uh professions that already
belong ideology is one that I'm very
familiar with
um how many the states that all belong
in this uh compact
already for how long have they been and
how has their experience been represent
manager py he did testify that this is a
new compact it has not yet gone into
effect in any state
and therefore that's impossible to
answer I thought I heard as two or three
states have already joined that's why
I'm trying to ask yes but it has not yet
gone into effect in any state because
you need to have I believe was seven
yeah yes it won't it won't go into
effect until seven states have passed
identical language and the compact was
only
written about a year and a half ago
thank okay representative Brown uh thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question um you said that uh two years
postgraduate supervised clinical
experience would be required um I I
think on page four on line seven it says
require applicants for clinical lure to
complete a period of supervised practice
I don't know if the two years is
elsewhere in here and I've missed it but
um just making if you do know that I'd
be interested to know where it is
thank you for your question I know that
um others are going to testify including
um Miss Courtney who was involved in
writing this and is the head of oplc so
I'm going to leave technical questions
like that to harer others who come after
me other questions thank you
representative for your
testimony and I'd like to mention to the
people eager to explain everything about
social work to us that we have 10 people
in favor no one opposed so I would very
much appreciate a your brevity uh Pam
sonot yes so my name is Pamela sinot and
I'm a licensed independent clinical
social worker with over 25 years of
experience in the field
I hold licenses in both New Hampshire
and
Massachusetts I once lived in
Massachusetts but currently reside in
New
Hampshire I am testifying today to tell
you how clients can be negatively
impacted by their therapist not being
able to see them if they are outside the
state where the clinician holds a
license I will share two case scenarios
the client names have been changed and
no identifying information will be
shared
Emma was a client I worked with off and
on since she was
13 at age 18 she left Massachusetts to
attend college in New Hampshire at the
time I was licensed in Massachusetts
only and this remained the case for most
of the time she was in college I was
able to meet with Emma only when she was
in
Massachusetts sometimes this meant her
coming home for the weekend specifically
so she could meet with
me diagnosed with an eating disorder
Emma would also occasionally struggle
with bouts of severe anxiety and
depression on one occasion when Emma was
struggling at
school she contacted the counseling
center and was told there was a two week
wait to see a
counselor in order to see someone sooner
Emma had to say she was experiencing a
mental health crisis
Emma emailed at me emailed me at this
time told me how she was feeling and
said she wish she could talk with me but
understood that I couldn't legally see
her another woman I saw I'll call her
Jess had a mental health crisis while
out of
state Jess was also a Massachusetts
client she had a trauma history and
suffered from anxiety with occasional
panic attacks Jess had entered into a
long-distance relationship with a
man uh with a man in the Pacific
Northwest during one of her trips out
west to see him he became very angry and
emotionally abusive and just emailed me
to let me know what was going
on she was feeling extremely anxious
stuck and wasn't sure what to do she
asked if we could
meet via email I asked some basic
questions to assess whether or not she
felt she was in danger and we briefly
discussed her options but I told her I
couldn't meet with
her I'm sure many of the clinicians
present today have had similar
experiences the more states that sign on
to the Social Work compact the better it
will be for clinicians and our clients
in addition it would also be less
expensive not to have to hold separate
licenses in separate
States holding different licenses a
clinician must also keep track of the
requirements of each state like the
number of continuing education credits
required every two years for example New
Hampshire requires 40 and Massachusetts
30 I urge you to support HB
1190 thank you very much are there any
questions representative Schmidt
yes they've they've been submitted
online I can submit this as well thank
you very much for that
okay Melbourne
moram hi back again uh melbour Moran Jr
uh I'm a licensed independent clinical
social worker um thanks for having me
back uh I'm just um here to uh speak on
behalf of not just myself but my agency
wonderlust um we do have uh quite
frequently a lot of uh clients that move
about uh as I said last time I was here
I I'm licensed in Massachusetts uh New
Hampshire and Washington State uh so um
I'm able to see folks that move in
between those States um but if someone
moves to another state uh no compact
exists at at the moment so we have to
try to quickly transition that client to
a new provider and and I know the U
you're all aware the shortages you know
weight list can vary depending on where
you are and if you have a long-standing
established relationship with a patient
uh that you've been seeing for quite
some time and then they're being moved
to another state uh it's hard to
transition someone let alone find a
provider um and what's often happening
is someone will move they're on a wait
list and there's no ability to do like a
warm handoff you maybe might send some
records a few months down the road but
you just can't offer that Psychotherapy
care if they're not in a state that
you're licensed in this compact will
alleviate some of that I know with my uh
mental health uh licensed uh clinical
Mental Health Counselors I believe that
compact does have seven or more States
and it's in in enacted but uh I might
not be right about that but for example
if they were transferring someone uh to
another state
and they were part of that compact
that's already passed here in New
Hampshire they could still see that
person whether they want to continue
with that person or hand them off until
they find someone in person uh that's
good good care uh right now we can't
even do that with uh social work because
the compacts not even passed um but just
in general I think um having the ability
to not terminate care I my agency takes
Tri care uh which is a military
insurance and quite frequently people
are moving uh last week one of my
patients is moving to Washington hey I
get to still see them but a couple
months prior to that they're moving to
Arkansas another uh patient so I can't
see them uh it just uh it just it's
frustrating to patients they want to
stay with you and uh and then finding
someone that's qualified to provide the
care uh with all the weight L is is a
whole another thing so I'll keep my uh
comments brief right thank
you represent manager py thank you madam
chair thank you uh for taking my
question are you clientele the
transitioning from one state to another
mostly younger High School to college or
college back that kind of or is it
across the board age-wise I would put
them in uh to different categories we
have the military category of folks who
are either uh in military or their
spouses uh as a patient and they're
being moved around or you have the
college kids that are going uh to
college uh who Maybe you've seen
throughout High School uh and now
they're going to Florida or uh Maine or
another uh State and um then you have
just the uh working professionals like
in NASA Bae is a very uh popular
employer in marac and everywhere else in
the State uh so you'll get a lot of
Engineers that'll be moving their
families around uh but they might be
here in nashille for a year and then
they have to move to another state uh as
part of their work uh so the the working
professionals is another group that we
see that are often moving and you know I
don't know about anyone here but let's
keep the phds working on nuclear weapons
uh in mental health care without losing
a provider when they're moving from
state to
state thank
you okay thank you very
much Susan
ankle hello thank you um so much for the
opportunity to testify today I'm a
licensed clinical social worker and I
live in Hoppington New Hampshire before
the pandemic I was um working in
Manchester um in a pediatric behav um
pediatric clinic um as an integrated
Behavioral Health clinician so I saw all
my clients in person and then during the
pandemic um all of us had to switch to T
Health which was something that everyone
had to adjust to um I was able at that
time started a new private practice and
saw you know all of my clients actually
just through the screen for the first
year um I will say it was amazingly
effective um really built strong
relationships with each of these clients
and then when that um ended now most of
my um clients in private practice are in
person occasionally um that will switch
to like because of weather or health um
to tell health so I think this tella
Health piece because it's so effective
for behavioral health and mental health
is a reason why this compact um is so
important and will work so well I have
three situations where um I've had to
kind of um adjust because of the
inability to um have this social work
compact one is a client that I've worked
with for several years um as you
described a high school student I
started seeing her when she was in
Middle School in person and then she
went to college and we developed a
really strong relationship um and she
did has done so well but this was a huge
transition we know with youth these
transitions are times where of you know
where having support is really important
um I haven't been able to see her she's
uh uh because of the compact she's
actually in a state in North Carolina
and have seen her when she's come back
and she's made some trips back um for
that you know and made sure to see me um
evidence shows that for social work or
for um mental health that it is the
relationship that shows the is the most
important thing when we think about um
people doing well with their mental
health care that that relationship they
have with their clinician is the key
rather than you know the form or the you
the mode of um the modality of treatment
so being able to maintain this
continuity of relationships is really
important um often with youth they won't
find someone else they just it takes so
long to build that trust and
relationship that they will just wait um
the second um situation is actually
personal um I have elderly parents who
are um live in Massachusetts and who
have needed my care and as a result of
it I went ahead and got licensed in
Massachusetts I don't have any clients
in Massachusetts but for the sole
purpose that I'm having to go to um
support them and need to continue to be
able to have access to my clients in New
Hampshire so I actually went through the
process of being licensed it was very
timec consuming and and costly and I'm H
I was happy to do it but it is certainly
a burden um the third was um I have a a
daughter who had a terrible ski accident
in Montana a year ago and so I had to in
an emergency go out and spend a month in
that state I went through the process of
trying to get licensed in
Montana I went and had to get
fingerprinted and did all the paperwork
but and decided that I was going to risk
my license to go I had to spend time
there I saw my clients online tell
Health but I was just going through the
process of getting licensed it actually
was going to take more than that month
to actually be licensed in Montana but I
had this dilemma um do I leave my
patients you know at risk and not having
any access to me or and do I you know
support my daughter who needed 100% care
so those were three situations where a
compact um you know kind of just would
play out and I really hope that you all
can support this today and thank you so
much for your time listening to my
testimony thank
you Donna Moren or Mo
sorry
hello I I uh retired mostly from being a
private practitioner here in New
Hampshire
on June 1st but I I'm also planning to
continue to do some Private teleah
health work I I was I worked at
Riverbend for seven years uh and then I
was in private practice a couple of
blocks away from here on Union Street
for 30 years and I I am very much in
favor of this bill I believe the
psychologists have already had the their
a psych pack I I think since
2019 and social workers do um very
similar work especially in private
practice um the times that I ran into
this issue were mostly with like the
what's already been said uh sco students
who I had treated that went away to
college uh and this would provide an
opportunity for continuity of care with
them also during the pandemic because we
did so much tella health it would be
much more convenient to be able to
continue to see people who were not in
town there were there or in the state
but I also treated a lot of people who
uh started working remotely and
sometimes one of my clients was working
uh from another state and wanted to
continue with care uh so so this came up
quite frequently and I'm very happy to
see this opportunity uh for this bill to
pass thank
you thank
you representative
peeterson thank you madam chair and
apologies for my being out of breath I
just ran up the back stairs from my
committee uh for nearly 30 years I've
been co-founder and part-time CEO of a
Wellness Center uh in Kingston that
combines family practice medicine three
providers counseling two Master's level
certified therapists and a massage
therapist over the years the lack of
interstate compacts has hurt us as we
sought to bring in trained professionals
with no black marks against them in
their records from out of state and in
two occasions they had to kind of cool
their Jets here in New Hampshire while
they went through yet another licensing
process here this bill if signed into
law would speed up the process for
organizations like mine a process which
I believe is
unnecessary I don't know all the details
in this bill but I do know that Lindsay
Courtney the head of our oplc was part
of the group that developed the one that
is in this bill and so if anybody says
well isn't there the danger that we're
not looking after New Hampshire
interests I think that's the answer to
that question so I would just encourage
us please pass this bill it will help
people who hire professionals like
myself to get our job done in a more
expeditious
way thank
you okay director
Courtney
good afternoon Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc I wish to um
testify in support of House Bill 1190
I'm not going to explain why I think
this is uh a fantastic opportunity from
a portability standpoint but I do want
to offer my assistance in answering any
questions regarding the technical
aspects of the bill um I would just
point out that much of this is a boiler
plate it cannot be changed absolutely
can't be changed in order for the
compact to be effective
um the sections that I think we should
be primarily concerned about are section
three which concerns outlines what a
state has to do to enter the compact in
order to be able to participate in
section 4 which explains what the social
worker has to do in order to be issued a
multi-state
license I also just want to note that
there are essentially two different
types of compacts there's uh the compact
that's contemplated in in this bill
which is the the multi-state model which
is that you get a license in your home
state and you can practice in any other
compact state that's the model that
nursing uses and so you only have to
have one license one fee one set of
continuing education
requirements other compacts use a
privilege to practice model which
requires the person to get licensed
initially in their home state and then
essentially apply to a body for a
privilege to practice they have to pay a
separate
um the difference there is that you know
who's practicing in your state so that's
basically the policy uh the policy
reasoning behind why you would choose
one versus the other in addition to
portability the compact offers uh the
opportunity for the states not the
opportunity requires the states to share
data um particularly regarding
investigations significant investigative
information and complaints and so I
think that's the difference between what
we did last year with House Bill 59 4
and essentially allowing for Universal
licensure in in New Hampshire um this
Pro provides an opportunity for us to
exchange that information so that we can
alert other states when there's
something going on that is not
considered public information but that
could impact that person's ability to
practice in that other state it provides
that information exchange and so I think
from that perspective is more protective
of the public then um traditional
portability uh would offer so section
four which you can find let's see
starting way at the bottom at page four
um and onto page five it outlines what a
social worker would have to do in order
to meet the
requirements and representative Brown
you asked a question regarding the hours
requirements and I would draw your
attention to looks like paragraph 4 um
this is where the 3,000 hours or the two
full years of postgraduate supervised
clinical practice is specified it's in
the social worker part of the bill um as
opposed to the state participation part
of the bill um but essentially uh the
social worker would have to pass a
clinical category qualifying National
exam which we already require um attain
a master's degree fulfill a practice
requirement which is what we already
require beyond that I'd be happy to take
any questions but I know you have others
wishing to testify so I don't want to
take up too much of your time thank you
representative representa groa your
co-sponsor
sir sorry representative um MTI thank
you madam chair um my question is with
the you said the nursing has this
portability so we can have the visiting
nurses from other parts of the country
correct will this open up that
recruiting or getting more help in
social work if this portability is
established for providers traveling
providers
yeah so I what we so when we were
drafting
this we felt very strongly that this
model was the better model for this
profession in particular because some of
the issues that you heard before me
surrounding teleah health and a client
going on vacation or a client um going
to college or um and and so for those
reasons we thought that uh allowing the
flexibility of not having to get the
privilege to practice every time
somebody opted to go to a different
state even
temporarily um would be the better fit
for this profession so it could
certainly help with
recruiting represent broa thank you I
have two questions the first question is
um I think one of the one of the
drawbacks to this to this type of
compact is that we have no say in the
compact itself which to some members of
the committee is a concern so can you
address that concern and I do have a
follow-up question to that after
so I think you have a say to the extent
that you can either choose to adopt it
or not you can also choose to um repeal
it um at any time and then the other
thing is that each state has to uh
nominate or provide a delegate um to the
compact commission which participates in
the ru making obligation and I'm
currently the compact commission member
for the Mental Health commission
essentially um we go and we we work with
the other state Commissioners and we
adopt rules um and there are
requirements and the notice and an
opportunity to be heard um as it relates
to rule making so I think the state does
have through that delegate does have the
opportunity to continue to participate
in the
compact I don't know if that answers
your question follow follow so so in
that rule making process do they have a
similar is the ru making process similar
to what we have in New Hampshire yes
there's uh notice there's public
meetings there's public hearings there's
opportunity for comment requirement to
respond to
comments it's very similar followup
followup and is that those public
hearings are they accessible by
residents of New Hampshire they public
key notice for us or for other states
that are part of the compact yes they're
often held virtually um I do think the
compact commission meets once a year in
person if they can although there's
always members who attend remotely and
the public typically attends remotely
but they're welcome in in person as well
okay and last question follow up thank
you um why would New Hampshire choose to
withdraw from a compact what be with
some of the reasons that some like for
example in the EMT compact why we did we
withdraw from
that so I can't speak for the
legislature I think there were some
concerns about essentially it um
instead of bringing people in could
bring you know take people out of New
Hampshire um but I think the primary
concern with a comact is one do we want
to promote
portability um yes I think we do do we
want to ensure Public Safety through a
standardized standardized set of rules
that the states have agreed to these uh
standards have been
negotiated by the participating States
and then as States enter into the
compact they agre ageing to that
contract it's both a contract and a
statute so for some states they are
basically um raising their standards
that they would otherwise typically so
we're all agreeing to the same set of
standards and I think from that
perspective it's to promote the public I
I I know that there's the argument that
it's unconstitutional I would disagree
with that
um so I think it's hard for me to play
Devil's Advocate and and explain why you
would would would not join the compact
thank you representative Simon thank you
madam chair thank you director for
taking my question I wasn't going to ask
it but you kind of alluded to it in your
testimony so I figured I might um is
there anything in the compact um that
would prohibit a large Social Work
Corporation from forming let's say in
Nebraska because Nebraska joined the
compact of driving down prices uh or
giving greater wages in that area and
since tella health is such a large
component of the compact as we've
already heard testimony to um basically
Outsourcing all of the on-site care in
New Hampshire out of state or a vast
majority of it to a large corporation
and then not having as many instate
clinicians as we presently have so
working the other way as opposed to
Bringing people in like you said we'll
be exporting people to some other state
that you know I I think if you allow for
portability there's always going to
be a potential that
people are going to relocate and
continue to seek to do services in New
Hampshire um what I would say to that
though is that we have a fantastic State
and wouldn't people who live here want
to keep living here
um practically I just don't see that
happening but you know I think that's a
possibility it's always a possibility
when you talk about
portability thank you very political
question answer to the question you've
been around us too long I think
um my other concern uh with this is you
you discuss the rul making process um
and on page 16 I believe it is of the
compact it says that um those rules
would have the force of law in all of
the states in which they're
implemented so I do have a concern so
clarify this for me if I'm wrong um that
although we would have a delegate on the
compact
commission members from other states
who would be the majority because we
would obviously only be one um would
have the ability to basically create
laws that would go into effect in the
state of New Hampshire which we would
then have to be reactive
to is that correct I think that's true I
think the important thing to remember
about rules is that you can only adopt
rules provided you have Ru making
Authority so it's within the four
corners of of this bill what the ru
making Authority would be limited to um
you know what is the qualifying National
exam and I know that's very
controversial in the social work field
but what is the qualifying naal National
exam is is a question that the
commission is going to have to address
at some point you know if if the rules
were out of line with what we in New
Hampshire wanted to see then the only
choice would be to repeal it and and and
no longer participate in the
compacts thank you very much yes but as
we know the difference between Ru making
and lawmaking is that rule making is a
little bit more Nimble um and can happen
a little bit quicker than we were able
to so one of my concerns would be and
correct me if I'm mistaken on this if a
rule were to pass say in May of of this
year say we were in the Compact and a
rule came in and we just really didn't
like it that basically puts us on our
heels until next January at the earliest
February maybe March we could be a year
out before we could adequately respond
to that rule would that not be the case
I think that's true although my
experience in being on being the
commissioner for the Mental Health
compact is that the rule making process
is extremely slow goinging extremely
slow goinging we're still we're still
working our way through some rules right
now
um and they're they're pretty basic
rules uh you know this is where you
would send in information or this is the
examination that we will accept um
I guess is
there is there a particular issue that
you think would be somewhat
problematic given the ru making
Authority that's contained in the
document um if you could Point me
because I'm obviously looking at it um
one of our newer bills that I'm looking
at to where that is outlined in the in
the bill itself so I can take a closer
look at that that would be helpful yeah
I think section speaks to um the ru
making Authority generally and it's
pretty basic or general and vague it
says the commission shall promulgate
reasonable rules in order to effectively
and efficiently Implement administer the
purposes and provisions of the
compact um it also provides that the
rule shall be invalid if a court of
competent jurisdiction holds that the
rule is invalid so beyond legislation
there's always the opportunity to seek a
court order if if it's if the New
Hampshire believes that the commission
has exceeded um the scope of its
regulatory
Authority
um so
essentially anything that
is discussed in the compact if you will
um in terms of the state participation
in the in in in the compact there's R
making authority of for that and then
there's R making authority to flesh
out um the social worker participation
in the compact there's rule making
Authority
regarding um who gets to be a delegate
um that's outlined in the compact but we
just did a rule for mental health um
concerning you know the nomination
process and how do we officially uh send
over a delegate um how do you issue the
license establishment of the compact
commission these are all the different
sections where you would have Ru making
authority pursuant to section 12 okay
thank you very much you're welcome in
the past some of the concerns that this
committee has had have been around fees
because the commissions do have the
opportunity to charge and assess fees
our experience has been that the fees
are pretty nominal um I think nursing is
about $5,000 a year um I think we just
paid cacked and it was a couple of
thousand it wasn't it was very nominal
as a state we have the authority to pass
that cost on off onto the ly if we so
choose in New Hampshire we haven't done
that um essentially the default is
everybody gets a compact license if they
qualify for one or unless they don't
want one but other states do charge a
different rate for compact versus
non-compact but that's another area of
controversy that I think this committee
has raised in the
past good thank youone
goalie thank you madam
chair you stated that you think
portability works and works
well my question is is portability with
when we look to nursing
compacts working as well as it should
when I look
at travel nursing agencies and travel
nurses filling positions for from state
to state and bouncing around from place
to place I think has driven up the cost
of
healthare and not allowed folks or
individuals to stay in the places where
they're licensed but instead chase the
dollar and what would prevent this
compact from having these individuals do
the
same
so I will say that without the nursing
compact
I we would not have been able to make it
through Co in the way that we were going
we we we were headed um I mean I was
getting calls on other professions
weekends nights can we issue this
license quickly I don't I have to shut
down this unit because we don't have a
respiratory care practitioner um can we
do this I think that's a separate issue
um Workforce that lenser is not lenser
is not going to Sol Workforce at all um
I think it be I think it can be part of
the solution in terms of eliminating
unnecessary requirements but I think
representative what you what you
highlight is an issue that's that
concerns Workforce if we had enough
Workforce um to meet the demand then
there wouldn't be this essential price
gouging that we see um but that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't offer people the
flexibility and remove unnecessary
barriers that portability presents for
people who who who need to move
around I think they're two separate
issues followup
followup I I'll leave that issue go but
I will disagree on that um the other
question I have is I look at this and I
go to
page
14 and can you tell me why this
commission needs qualified immunity
defense and
indemnification yeah I can because
essentially they're acting as a quas
state body um they're a public entity
because they're seated by state
representatives and so just like every
other state official um and state public
body
uh who receives qualified certain
certain immunities this body does as
well they're acting on behalf of their
state it's a public body and that's why
the delegate has to be either a board
member who's a state official or a staff
person uh like myself who's also a state
official and is entitled to
immunity represent thank you so last
year we had um we representative goalie
reminding me of the registry that we put
in place for the traveling nurses we
might remember that yes I do and I
understand that in some cases rather
than going through this registry nurses
just decided to um come on board to New
Hampshire and work here in some of these
um either County homes or nursing homes
so first I'd like you to verify that and
second did did the compact help with
that because they were practicing in
another state this is about the nursing
compact is it kind of a loaded question
yeah can you repeat the first part or
rephrase yes because we we because we
instituted this registry yes rather than
being registered some of these sorry
some of these traveling nurses just
decided to work just took a job at a
local place correct right yeah
absolutely so and then and did that give
was that part of that ability to quickly
pick up a job part of that portability
from the nursing compact absolutely I
think I think nursing in particular but
I think we saw the greatest need with
interesting the data that we have which
is as you know very limited but the data
that we have from the emergency
licensing experiment experiment shows
that during covid where we saw where we
initially saw the greatest need in terms
of portability was in the mental health
professions because people were seeing
their clients in their
offices and literally overnight they
moved to a tele Health platform and if
they resided in Vermont and the client
was in New Hampshire now they need a New
Hampshire license where they previously
saw the client in Vermont the several
thousand initial several thousand
emergency licenses we issued were for
mental health providers primarily we
didn't have to issue nursing because
nursing could just work as long as they
were part of the compact um there is a
need here I think particularly for those
circumstances that were addressed by
folks previously um that I think will be
served with this with this
compact representative
Simon thank you madam chair sorry it's a
it's a long bill um so I'm not trying to
pick on you on anything oh you're fine
um so you had mentioned before for that
if there was concern uh you could
adjudicate that issue being in
interstate compact how does that work
what level of Court would hear that
adjudication the state in which it's
making the claim in the state court
would you have to go to a federal
circuit court where where would that
complaint be made in in a compact o I
think I would I want to research that a
little bit before I give you the answer
um sure that's fine and so maybe I can I
can follow it up with an email um I
think section 12
discusses
yeah my assumption would be Federal but
let me take a look at that and I can I
can send you an email and respond thank
you very
much representative goalie thank you
madam chair uh one last question see he
brought up that
issue what would happen or how would a
case be
handled if there was an action brought
up on someone who was here in New
Hampshire on let's say a Texas
license license E from Texas here in New
Hampshire does something egregious has a
complaint filed against them
M what then happens so I understand that
they have a Texas license home state
license and they're working here on a
New Hampshire license so under that
scenario New Hampshire could adjudicate
the matter and say you're no longer
allowed to work in New Hampshire because
we only can control what's in our
jurisdiction because the home state is
in Texas we notify Texas Texas could do
the
same and by Texas revoking the license
it removes that person's ability to
practice in any of the compact States so
we always have the ability to adjudicate
claims in New Hampshire and to allow or
disallow tell people they can't work
here based on misconduct but if you are
the jurisdiction of the home state
license if you take action that action
um basically removes you from being able
to participate in the compact
followup so if there is a hearing on the
matter it's going to take place in Texas
for that license to
be whether it's the person's going to
maintain their license or lose their
license or whatever actions taken
there'll be a hearing in the home state
what H what would happen
to the individuals who would be
testifying in favor or one way or the
other from New Hampshire would they be
traveling to Texas to be at that hearing
to justify their concerns so we we could
hold a hearing in New Hampshire and
that's that's what we typically do in
nursing um is we if the conduct occurred
in New Hampshire where all the witnesses
are located we hear it in New Hampshire
um and typically because you know based
on reciprocal discipline states are
um they don't they can't collaterally
attack uh a finding of another
jurisdiction so Texas could certainly
hear it
um as well um and adjudicate the claim
my experience has been that we work
collaboratively with that jurisdiction
and figure out how to handle testimony
and the like but we often have witnesses
who appear in our cases remotely and
courts I mean it's very common for
courts to do as well
follow
up it's kind
of it was could be in New Hampshire but
could be in Texas yeah so it my question
is where is it happening because I mean
I I would like to
know if it was a New Hampshire liccy and
was working in
Texas and something happened down in
Texas
to get their license revoked in New
Hampshire and it took place in Texas
you're going to just go by what they
said in Texas instead of I thought the
law here in hampsh was that you have to
hold a hearing or an appeal if they
choose to appeal
that so I apologize there's a lot to
unpack um and I don't want to give you a
lawyer response but it's always going to
be it depends it depends on the facts
and that's the case whether you're part
of the compact or not so what we're
talking about is the comact you know do
you want to have lenes be able to
practice in states with one license or
do you want them to have to get a
license in every other state so under
the scenario that you presented me
somebody is originally from Texas has a
Texas license let's say they're not part
of the compact has a Texas license comes
to New Hampshire has a New Hampshire
license commits misconduct in New
Hampshire we adjudicate that claim that
person has and we notify Texas through
the National Practitioner Data Bank they
get
notification and there's a a theory of
the law basically you've already had one
bite at the Apple to dispute whether the
facts happened as they as they did and
so Texas has to have a hearing in order
to discipline you but the question is
not did you commit the misconduct the
question is whether or not we should
impose sanctions based on the finding of
the New Hampshire Court that's
consistent with how courts handle it and
that's how administrative bodies handle
it now that same scenario would happen
under the compact but the question is
are we talking about one license or we
talking about
two one according to this
contact correct and so you could
adjudicate in New Hampshire you could
say you no longer have the option to
work in New Hampshire if they had a
Texas Home State Texas would take a look
at it and they would say okay we don't
want you working anywhere because we
have the home state we're going to
revoke your license and now you don't
have a compact license and you can't
work anywhere New Hampshire can only
take away what's in New Hampshire but
because Texas is the home state it can
take away your opportunity to work
anywhere but it's not unlike what we see
under the other scenario which is
non-compact the compact is not going to
change the way we address it I guess is
what I'm trying to
say
representative gold thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question on page
16 under the at the bottom of the page
under the rules the commission um shall
have the force of law that uh
representative Simon had mentioned it
goes on to say that if the state has
laws on the books that are contradict
with the rules the commission comes up
with then the state law supersedes the
rules is that correct yes that's what it
states and follow follow so is there so
that means that if the state was in
opposition to a rule the state could
enact a law that would counteract the
rule correct they could thank
you thank you very much thank
you
Sam
Hawkins good afternoon Madam chair
members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today I'll keep my comments
brief uh my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the
public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide on behalf of Nomi Hampshire I'm
here today to speak in support of House
Bill 1190 I'd like to Echo the comments
of previous speakers of the Grave impact
of the healthare uh Workforce shortage
especially on Mental Health Providers
resulting in excessive weight times for
patients and increased risk of harmful
burnout for dedicated professionals one
in five adults and one in six youth aged
6 to 17 experience a mental illness each
year in New Hampshire as of 2021 more
than half of people with a mental health
condition in the US did not receive any
treatment Nomine Hampshire has heard
countless stories of people who were
given a list of up to 20 providers by
their insurance um just to discover that
none of them were accepting new patients
the average delay between the onset of
mental illness symptoms and treatment is
11 years when individuals with mental
illness receive the right services at
the right place at the right time fewer
folks will end up homeless hospitalized
or incarcerated this bill would help to
address the mental health Workforce
shortage in our state expand access to
care for granite Staters and enable
continuity of care for existing patients
for these reasons we urge you to vote
OTP for this bill happy to answer any
questions but I'll defer technical
questions thank
youy thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um Nami New Hampshire
is a chapter of the national chapter and
you have several programs in terms of
Suicide Prevention first episode
psychosis and those kind of stuff how
does this back up the policy aspect of
Nami that's providing to the health care
providers shortage or programs access to
Mental Health Providers thank you for
your question uh if I understand it
correctly um this would not expand
access to our programs as I understand
it but of course from a policy
perspective it is our priority that uh
folks who need Services get access to it
and we see this bill is doing just that
thank you representative Simon thank you
madam chair um perhaps you would be able
to clarify this question for me um we
know that there's a shortage in the
state of New Hampshire is there a
surplus someplace
else
um and and I don't mean that to be
tongue and- cheek it just seems like if
there's a shortage everywhere I'm just
trying to figure out where the
additional Workforce is coming to
lighten the the load or or how you see
that working sure uh thank you for the
question I'm not a Ware of a surplus I'm
sure there there are other states that
um have a higher population have less
rural areas we know specifically for
people in rural areas of the state um
they they are seeing that shortage more
than some people in the southern aspect
of the state and tell Health would open
that up but I'm not aware of an existing
Surplus that I could speak to thank
you thank you very much representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair following
up on representative Simon's
question uh
I if we have a reciprocity situation
which we do in a number of our
professions isn't already the case
people could come here to New Hampshire
uh based on as one of the earlier
Witnesses testified this is such a
desirable place to live as long as you
got an unlimited wallet um uh such a
desirable place to live that we are
already attracting people from other
areas to come and practice their
profession here is not that that not the
case in
in response to representative Simon's
situation as well thank you for the
question I think it is absolutely true
that many people moved to New Hampshire
for uh a lot of the Fantastic things it
has to offer um but this bill goes
beyond that to college students who
maybe grow up here go out of state want
to maintain continuity of care uh people
who winter in a different state and want
to maintain continuity of care it's
important for that aspect as well thank
you representative gold thank thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question having a family member who uses
these services and fits the um scenario
you described even when there is not a
surplus of
workers do you find that the lag in
services that can be created by waiting
on the wait list to find a replacement
provider when there's not um this is
detrimental to the well-being of those
seeking Services thank you for the
question yes absolutely any delay in
treatment when it is absolutely critical
can lead to progression of the
seriousness of the illness that can see
real drastic negative
outcomes thank
you thank you thank you very
much Ken
snow
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee uh for your time today I
will be very brief because it feels as
if many of the points I wanted to make
have already been made quite
articulately by other members of this
making a presentation but I would simply
say my name is Ken snow
I'm from
Manchester I have been in New Hampshire
for since
1966 and been an active participant in
and witness to the development of the
community health system in this state
which in many ways we can be very proud
of and you people have all played a
great role in that along with a lot of
other people across the state that have
worked very hard over the years to
change what was at one time a very
primitive kind of system of care into a
much more modern system of care this is
a bill that attempts to fine-tune that
and do it an even better job by
maximizing the opportunity for us to
attract qualified uh practitioners to
come into the state and and and and to
work along with the rest of us to make
that happen uh I would I understand your
concerns and I'm glad you're looking at
this so carefully I do just comment as
my it was my impression having read this
very lengthy Bill myself that the answer
to representative goalie who I know he's
also from Manchester
we know each other I would simply say
keep in mind the Hampshire still
controls what happens in the Hampshire
no matter what happened in Texas they
can rule either go along with New
Hampshire or not but in the end that
person still cannot practice in New
Hampshire so we still have control over
that and I I hope that somewhat
reassures people that we're not subject
to the whim of another State's decision
how it impacts how our citizens are
going to be served uh and unless there
are any other questions I I I I can only
say it's been my privilege to be a
member of nasw which is a National
Association of Social Workers I
celebrated my 62 years as a member of
that organization and I've been an
active Advocate mental health ever since
and uh I hope I'll have the opportunity
to continue doing that thank you very
much for your time thank you for your
testimony and your
service Warren
Perry
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee for the record Warren Perry
I'm the deputy agent general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran service Services uh
in that role we oversee uh you know
essentially the the veteran and Military
and their families constituency of the
State of New Hampshire as it uh uh as it
pertains to services and you know
resources that are available to them we
believe that compacts are generally good
right they increase access to services
and they increase the ease by which uh
transitioning military members can
continue to get licenses and practice as
they move into or out of the state of
New Hampshire so from that perspective
the department endorses the law I I
would make two comments one is this we
testified similarly to the the exact
bill that passed the Senate on February
8th uh in the senate senate 318 I'm sure
you're all aware of and to
representative Simon's question about
Surplus versus you know deficit of
services I would submit that if it's
easier to get licenses and to get care
in more places because we have a compact
then we more efficiently use the limited
resources that we have so I would just
look at it not necessarily from a surf
Surplus and deficit perspective but from
now we have a bigger pool of resources
that we can tap into and they can be
more efficiently used so I I I try to
look at kind of glass half full kind of
perspective of that that perspective so
subject to your questions that's my
statement and I'll I'll be happy to
answer any questions thank you
representative Simon the maner py thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question um and yeah no I mean I feel
like representative G's point was well
made and and I had that in consideration
when I asked the question as well that
um I think they're two different issues
um continuity of care obviously it's
good to keep somebody with a
practitioner we think that's fairly
obvious uh my question was more along
the lines of if each practitioner is
already stretched to their limit um how
does opening up this you know uh
increase the pool you know so that
there's there's more access to more care
because everybody's already strapped now
it would make sense to me that if
everybody isn't actually all you know
strapped with their maximum amount of um
patients then then that that could be of
assistance but all the testimony that
I've heard today is that they end up on
a waiting list for four weeks six weeks
because they can't get in to see anybody
because they're already booked up and
they don't have room for for more
patients so just wanted to make sure
that I clarified my question and if you
have anything that you could add to that
that' be be grateful I certainly don't
disagree with your with your premise I
mean nobody has enough hours in the day
to get all the work done that they need
to get done but if we create places
where we can get into the system more
places that we can get into the system
we can more efficiently use the limited
resources so I certainly agree like as a
bureaucrat like how do we create
capacity in the system is like one of
the things I try to do every day so I I
didn't disagree with you I just offered
an alternative view yeah thank
you man py thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question uh two part
one is in terms of tele medicine and
using that
resources of how did that impact during
the covid and having access to Tele
medicine in the rural areas in New
Hampshire yeah so thanks thanks for the
question I'm not I'm not a social worker
I'm not an expert in tele medicine so
I'm just going to say I know that the VA
used it effectively uh use tele medicine
effectively to get services to people
you know to my way of thinking it's not
the best way to do business but it's
better than nothing so that that's
that's just me I'd rather meet in person
so I I'm I'm going to not answer your
question because I just I'm not an
expert on tele medicine or the impact of
it I do know that the VA used it very
effectively both for physical health and
mental health during during Co
thank
you thank you very
much Lynn
Stanley thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony my name is LIN cier Stanley I
am the executive director of the
National Association of Social Workers
New Hampshire chapter I am a licensed
independent clinical social worker and I
live in
Penacook previous uh testimony has
really covered a lot of the points that
I was uh that I would make I will
highlight this helps social workers in
that they do not social workers already
have especially along the borders
multiple licenses they already have them
they've they if they have
uh clients who go to Florida in the
winter time they've already got the
teleah health license in Florida the
thing is that they're paying pay for
that thousands of dollars every year
every other year the
multi-state uh Social Work compact will
alleviate some of that cost that social
workers are are paying right now this is
a benefit to New Hampshire citizens who
are clients
they students who go off to college
people who go off uh in the in the
winter time one of the ways ways that it
will impact uh Workforce is when a
student from let's say Vermont goes to
un they have a therapist a social worker
that they're already seeing when they
come to New Hampshire they'll be able to
continue seeing that social worker they
will not need to find a new one here
right so that has there there isn't one
spot being taken up if you will this
also helps our agencies when a social
worker who is licensed in another state
moves to New Hampshire and they got a
job they now need to wait until they are
licensed in New Hampshire in order to
start seeing clients that can that can
be a few weeks that can be a couple
months with the social work compact a
social worker coming from a uh a state
that that is part of the compact will be
able to start day one they'll be able to
start seeing
clients which is a benefit to our
clients to our agencies and to that
social worker who would like to start
making a living as soon as possible
uh the the issue about uh traveling
social work is in so traveling nurses
has come up
because I work with student Social Work
students I'm always looking at indeed
I'm looking to see what jobs are out
there I I see traveling nurse ads all
the time I've seen one over the last few
years one ad for a traveling social
worker it's just not a thing it's just
the the reason the the the primary
difference I think between the social
workers and the nurses is a lot of this
work is being done through telea Health
it's not nobody's traveling any place
are there going to be exceptions to that
I'm sure um however the the traveling
Social Work piece is just not something
that we're seeing happening um as far as
big
companies you know mental health
corporations we're already seeing that
um it's a great equalizer it gives
people a lot of access uh but from a lot
of uh feedback that I've received from
social workers is that it's a lot of
puppies and sunshine for the first
couple months and then the reimbursement
rates are
pretty like a third less than what uh
insurance and Medicare and Medicaid is
paying now so I'm not sure how long that
that's going to be that's going to be a
thing but but it will open it up so that
uh those social workers who are working
for those
corporations uh will be able ble to see
a greater number number of clients which
from an equity standpoint is is good
news for for
clients I'll I'll leave my testimony
right there and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have thank
you representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my
question you stated that there really is
no traveling social work out there now
but is it not correct there is no
compact unlike a nurses who have a
compact as the reason why there's no
traveling social workers I thank you for
the question everything is is possible
but for many social workers who will be
utilizing this compact it's for
Psychotherapy it's for telea health
right it's either because the social
worker has gone someplace or the client
has gone someplace and being able to
maintain that continuity of
care I believe the the difference is a
hospital or a where they're attending to
physical health they need that nurse
there they in order to provide the
care that isn't usually the case with
social workers that that it is a
requirement that that that that that
position be filled I know there are
exceptions to that but it's it's just
not the
same work requirement and the that the
social worker M must be present and on
staff follow follow and then the other
statement you made and a lot of other
folks have made is that they can
continue their continuity of care with
their client if they should travel
somewhere else outside of New Hampshire
sure isn't it only true they can
continue that care if the state that
client goes to is part of the contact
correct and from what I'm hearing now
the only two states that are are
Missouri and south coda is that correct
that is correct thank you we have the
model legislative language didn't come
out until February of last year which
was too late for
most legislative sessions and then you
have Montana that meets 990 days every
two years so it's all over the place
this is the first full legislative
session that Most states have where it's
been able to be introduced Missouri and
uh South Dakota
have gotten there uh I believe 27 other
states it's uh being heard um I think it
just came off the house floor in Vermont
today this
morning
okay representative
Schmid thank you madam chair let me
understand so if you this tella Health
situation if I'm uh a client of a
particular worker who's here in New
Hampshire and I want to and I'm
traveling
to Texas sure and I want to stay in the
care of
my of my doctor if you will
of my mental health
worker and I I'm in Texas I can't call
up the person back in New Hampshire and
have
them attend to me thank you for the
question if I'm in Texas you are
absolutely correct unless it if taex if
if I'm your if I'm your therapist you're
my client you're here in New Hampshire
I'm licensed in New Hampshire you go to
Texas the the the work is being done
Where You Are
which is in Texas if I'm not licensed in
Texas I am breaking the law by providing
services to you okay thank you yeah
representative
Manti thank you Madame chair
um gone the question is gone sorry I
didn't write it down it was a really
good question
too standard
law
good good all right that in that case
thank you Miss Stanley thank
you John de
Joy thank you madam chair member of the
committee for the record my name is John
dejoy I'm here today representing the
New Hampshire Psychological Association
NH HPA is a membership organization
which represents psychologists in the
state of New Hampshire what's coming
around is testimony from Dr Julie Walter
Dr Julie Walter is the chair of the
behavioral health advisory committee uh
who I directly work with on advocacy
issues uh she's asked me to convey to
you that nhpa strongly supports this
compact uh and to speak briefly to the
cact so as you heard this is not the
first compact newshire ented into it is
one in the line in fact there have been
four there have been four other comp
four this would be the fourth compact um
in The Last 5 Years the first of those
was in 2019 which were the psychologists
referred to as cypa um there were only
six states that adopted cypa seven
states adopted cypac before New
Hampshire did which made New Hampshire
an early adopter of the psychologist
compact today there are 41 states that
have adopted it and there are five
others that have active legislation
currently
the speed with which that compact has
grown indicates the need for portability
uh I think this would be very much the
same that while there are 27 States now
considering it in the next several years
it is highly likely there will be many
many more um with that I will end my
testimony thank
you representative man py you remembered
your question I take it I
did thank you madam chair so typically
what is the length of treatment or the
continui needed in social work or mental
health as this case is how long
typically what's the length of um
engagement between the provider and the
which needs the continuity thank you
very much for that question and while I
am a social worker I'm not a clinical
social worker so I would prefer to defer
that question to one of the clinical
social workers in the audience audience
perhaps Miss Stanley that was my
question thank
you I think it would be fair
representative maner py to say it's a
long time because someone testified that
a middle schooler was in treatment
throughout high school and into college
so you're talking 10 years that that was
my contrast I was trying to draw with
the nurses coming to a clinical which is
short term
okay thank you does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
1190 no then I'm closing the public
hearing what's
that well since we have two
subcommittees at 1:00 I don't think
we're going to vote on this although I
had planned to
originally uh we will be back at 1:00
here with the licensing subcommittee and
and the building code subcommittee will
be down in room
1222 um I know we got a couple bills
just uh show of hands who's here to
speak on
1222 I only see one is everybody else
here for
1408 okay all right thank
you well no it's it's public hearing any
okay and
you I I re and who you are you
representing someone
or okay all right thank
you
um all right one what I want to start
out with and is there were some
uh significant changes to the whole um
the PA statute that was U from Senate
Bill 228 in uh 202 two and questions
have been raised by some people as
to U you know what how what impact that
had why people see a need for something
further
so um you know if there's somebody who
is in support of this bill maybe
representing the Pas if you could come
up and address
that
um why don't you just come up and we'll
we'll work through it
but just
me for now yes
sir unless I don't think someone's going
to sit on your lap
so that would go viral yeah not for any
good re
reason Mr chair for the record my name
is David czy uh with Prospect Hill
strategies and I'm representing the
Society of New Hampshire Society of
physician assistants I was the one who
testified on their behalf during the
hearing and as I mentioned uh we do have
representatives from the from nispa as
well as the American Academy of Pas who
are uh in from out of town actually um
if they're in a better position to
answer some of the questions I have but
I guess first if they're from out of
town I'll ask you for you the question
on 228 since that's a New Hampshire sure
uh
issue so uh I think if I understood the
question uh correctly you were saying
okay we just we passed
228 now here uh in Senate Bill 228 two
years ago and now here we are with House
Bill
1222 um
so the Nisa did
uh you know request that Senate Bill 228
be introduced a few years ago and that
was the goal then was to take the first
step to
modernizing PA statutes and regulations
here in New Hampshire to recognize uh
modern how modern Healthcare is
delivered in the team setting uh and
that passed unanimously in both the
house and the Senate and was signed into
law by the governor uh the regulations
are I think now you know as we all know
that takes time then for the regs to
catch up but they're uh I believe now
final so that's in place uh and the what
the big there were two big changes in
that bill uh the first big change was
that it got rid of the concept of
supervision in statute and in regulation
so going back many years when the PA
profession was uh
first uh first came to be they were more
like assistance to Physicians and so as
time went on anytime they the state
state law said that there needed to be a
um a supervis an RSP a responsible
supervising physician form um signed by
a
doc that that doctor as time has gone on
the rules had changed so that that
doctor uh or any physician had to be
either in the building or accessible by
electronic means when when the PA was
practicing medicine uh
now the concern was that of course and I
think we've all had PA care for us it's
not like and I used the example at the
hearing it's not like a new waiter or or
waitress where they have the manager
kind of s behind them right there right
there please please well and so as we
know the docs you know doctors are not
supervising Pas when they're providing
care and so as time has gone on the
thought was let's remove the concept of
supervision and let's change it to
collaboration because that's what modern
Healthcare teams do if it's NPS if it's
Pas and so that's what Senate Bill 228
did it change the language to turn make
that a collaboration agreement and
actually set forth an statute that Pas
shall
collaborate but the collaboration
agreement still had to be signed by a
physician so there was still that legal
tether to a dock and no other provider
NPS don't have that at all and so we
made that change it was a good first
step uh and then the other important uh
change was that it removed it did remove
the liability of that physician who
signed that document so just because
they have their name on that document
shouldn't mean they could be held
responsible for the care that the PA
provides of course if they were somehow
involved in the care of that patient
then naturally they should be so that
that was also important because that
liability um
made it so that doctors would have to
carry either additional liability
insurance they had to be compensated for
that because they were responsible so
those were the two big
changes
um we were not aware that representative
Roser was bringing in HB 1222 this year
um and so we had always told we nispa
and I just the conquered lobbyist had
always told my colleag colleagues from
the if it was a medical association or
the other folks in town hey look you
know we are going we do want you know to
remove that signature that legal tether
um it's called independent practice but
it's really not that's a misnomer
because no no no healthc care provider
Prov uh practices independently they all
consult with each
other but nonetheless I said when we do
that we're certainly going to be
transparent we'll talk Etc then here was
this bill and so I said you know again
tactically politically you know we
didn't you know representative roach did
this but now we realize you know it's
long been since time if if NPS if nurse
practitioners can practice without any
kind of a collaboration agreement with L
education and less training right out of
school then certainly a PA should be
able to do the same if they've been 25
years into a career let alone maybe you
know a year or two out of school and so
we realize that there might be some
support and so we came to the hearing we
provided information and we said you
know this wasn't I guess for lack of a
better way to phrase it wasn't our idea
to do this now but here we are and so um
that I think is is where we are today uh
representative and I I apologize for
being typically longwinded that's okay
um and to members of the subcommittee
what I uh I don't want to block
questions what I'd like to do is um get
somebody from uh the who came here
representing the PA Association and then
see if anybody wants to speak on the
other side and then if we have questions
if if that's
acceptable and I did email over what was
your name again uh my name yes David czy
CI that's right yeah yeah so and in that
email uh thank you representative I did
uh there were two documents there was
like kind of a myths and facts about Pas
and then the education and experience
side by side with Pas and nurse
practitioners does anyone need a hard
copy of that CU I have copies here take
it if you got it okay yeah I'm all set
but yeah you can I see over there sorry
how are you I would all right um so you
said someone was here from the so Sarah
Lesley is the is the VP of the New
Hampshire Society of physician
assistants she's a PA here in New
Hampshire she's here and we do have
folks from the American Academy of uh
physician assistants from Washington uh
here as well so I I respect suggest they
may be able to answer some of the more
technical questions I can handle the
legislative policy type stuff why don't
we start with U Miss Lesley and we may
call you back up if we have questions
for you thank you I'll hand these out in
the meantime
y
yes I I believe I'm not on the
subcommittee correct so I I it may be
that I'm supposed to be down in 104
right at the moment but I can't be in
two places at one time but I'm very
interested in this bill so and I know
you'll allow me to participate except
not to vote but I'm investigating right
at the moment that's fine if you have to
go that's fine it's understand but I do
have some questions when you when you're
going to permit okay
um so I guess one kind of general
question is you know what what's the
reason for removing the collaboration um
is it not working um whatever if you
could address that General area good
morning I'm Sarah Lesley I know David
already introduced me but I'm the vice
president and the legislative co-chair
for the New Hampshire Society Pas and
I've been a PA for the past 14 years so
to answer the question you just asked
when we passed sorry go ahead I couldn't
hear you I apologize yeah can you hear
me now yeah better you have to be pretty
close to the mic Perfect all right so um
since we passed s228 two years ago we
thought that that was going to clear up
a lot of our issues because what we've
been finding is that uh employers and
Physicians don't want didn't want to
sign the supervising agreements because
of financial burden as well as
administrative burden um and liability
so we thought great we passed s228 it's
collaboration The Physician is no longer
liable for signing that uh agreement um
great however what's happened in the
last two years is not a lot has changed
there's still Physicians that don't want
to sign up because we still actually
have to provide medical malpractice for
that physician um because they can still
be sued by signing it however they us
they'll fall off eventually but I still
have to provide coverage for that
physician and so do the hospitals um in
order for them to sign that form now we
still also have Physicians that don't
want to sign so they have Pas that are
not being hired uh we heard from the
chair at this at Southern um Southern
New Hampshire Health the chair for the
family practice Division and they used
to have Pas and they've had to let go of
a lot of their seasoned Pas in in order
to hire new grad NPS because they've
lost the docks and they will not signed
the collaboration agreement so now
they're down to only four Pas and all
new grad NPS so they've lost a lot of
their experienced help and what was that
organ that was the department chair of
uh Southern New Hampshire health for
family
practice so they have 36 providers and
now they only have four Pas when it used
to be Physicians and PAs and now they
only have NPS because and newr NPS
because they don't want to sign the form
so we thought that changing it so the
doc was not liable for signing the form
we thought that making it so it wasn't a
supervisor form would have solved this
but it literally changed nothing so
that's why we're also back here
supporting this today because this is
ultimately we want parody with The NPS
because our training is if you look at
our clinical hours in school it's three
times that what a nurse practitioner
gets I'm a PA my brother's an
Interventional cardiologist my sister's
a nurse practitioner so we kind of got a
little bit of everything and even my
sister when if she said if it wasn't for
my brother and myself she's like my
training was nothing like what you had
because it's part-time online compared
to our full-time
iners medical it's our PA programs are
designed after Medical School whereas
nursy practitioners are designed after
the nursing model and unfortunately you
know now you don't even have to be a
nurse to go into NP school there are
programs such as Simmons that have
direct NP programs where you go in you
get your RN and NP at the same time with
very limited clinical hours and I've
heard some say well you know NPS are
better you know in the sense they they
should have independent practice I hate
saying that autonomous practice because
none of us practice independently we're
always leaning on each other doc PA I
have docs that come to me and ask me
questions because they know I'm better
at some things than they are and I ask
them questions that's just the way it
works um but you know with NP programs
they say opas are generalized you know
we're trained in all different areas of
medicine NPS are trained in one specific
area but now what we're finding is that
Family Practice NPS are hired and
they're put in the ICU instead of being
the ICU the adult Critical Care NP
programs that are supposed to be working
in the ICU so that's not even a valid
argument anymore um but so ultimately
that's why we're back here because 228
what we thought it was going to do did
not change anything at
all okay
um trying to get some notes here
so okay so you for one question is
you're mentioning NP I also there's the
term
um APRN what's the relation yes yes crnp
npnp they're all the same they just have
different acronyms all right uh qu uh
represent MTI thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um you said
that collaboration really that did not
happen or that did not change the
liability or malpractice so if uh the
the Physicians still carry that what
happens when that decouples will the Pas
need to take a higher malpractice or
liability insurance at that time perfect
thank you so much for the question um no
so we carry the same liability as the
Physicians right now as it is um however
what we have to do is especially pasas
that own their own practice they have to
still provide coverage for their medical
director um so what ends up happening is
now I still even though it's not liable
it says in statute the physician's not
liable for signing that form we still
have to pay extra to provide that
malpractice but we still carry the same
malpractice coverage that the Physicians
do and we always have so we've always
had our own and Physicians have their
own it's it stays the same follow up
thank you Mr chair um with the
malpractice it also has the or
organization that you work for except
when you have a private practice or
independent practice they also carry
liability for the practicing Physicians
or PA correct mhm and that's still a
practice yes this that won't change yes
yeah so like I work at Clear Choice MD
um in addition to having my own um
practice and they I get malpractice
through Clear Choice MD and I also
happen to buy my own because I don't
trust their malpractice to cover me
fully which I think a lot of providers
understand is a smart thing to do so
just to be clear um you said the Pas
have the same liability uh insurance as
a as an MD is it typically cost about
the same I know there can be differences
in Specialties for MDS but right so
that's hard to say because I honestly I
don't know how much everybody is paying
so I I can't say for sure I do know that
U premiums have gone up because of the
extreme judgments have have been coming
these 15 million $20 million judgments
so all the providers are seeing an
increase in our premiums um it could be
that the docs have to pay more but we
still have the same the 1 mil 3 mil
coverage that the Physicians also carry
some practices or Specialties may have
to carry more depending okay so kind of
a followup to that so do you uh
anticipate any change in the cost of the
insurance Pas if the collaboration
agreement requirement goes away well
without being an insurance company I
can't say for sure but my from what I
understand probably not other than the
fact that they're all just going up
unfortunately because of what's been
happening with um massive payouts okay
any other questions from the committee
for Leslie um I I'll get to you
representative Gould mapy and then
representative Schmidt uh just very
briefly thank you um Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question in your
testimony you talked about um you
compared a little bit nurse
practitioners and physicians assistant
my daughter I was trying to look up her
exact acronyms I'm dyslexic I'll say
them all wrong but she has her doctors
as a nurse practitioner and she um
develops palea care Care Pediatric padic
Care programs um in Hawaii and North
Carolina she is now at any rate we had a
lengthy conversation about this and
would you agree that basically seven
years out in practice a PA and an and an
advanced whatever nurse
practioner um I really performing equal
work that there's differences on both
sides I mean I can read you what she
said she would say the act opposite of
what you said that blah blah blah
physician assistants can have any
undergraduate degree we had to have a
Nursing degree I mean so there's
differences there subtle differences in
the at the end of the day would you
agree
that a physician's assistant is looking
at a more medical model curing disease a
nurse practitioner looks more at a
nursing taking care of the family but
both are practicing prescrib the scope
of services ultimately are the same yes
ma'am thank you for the question yes it
is 100% they are the same um especially
once you've had time and you've been
practicing um I would say that we can't
have any degree to go into PA program
because we actually have to have either
Premed or something like that because
you have a lot of prere in everything I
understand and I know there's going to
be those um but to answer your question
though yes you know especially when you
have um experienced practitioners yes
and there's plenty of studies that show
there's no bad outcomes whether it's an
NP or a pa um so nothing to put my NPS
down because again my sister would kill
me um and I I love The NPS that I work
with it's there's nothing against them
it's merely just looking at the facts of
Education followup follow up and so U my
daughter also said at the end of the day
she would hire a PA over a over an NP
who was more qualified and anyway she
loves P her Pas and so my my question is
um and I had to make a note of it here
because I'm so horrible with your
medical term terminology she is in North
Carolina which is a collaborative
Practice State so she as a nurse
practitioner just like the Pas in North
Carolina are under whatever lordship of
whatever God that yeah in New Hampshire
the nurse practitioners are independent
currently but the Pas are are under this
collaborative type of practice so it's
almost like we have a schizophrenia
going on where we have two professions
that have an equal scope of practice but
they're treated differently because of
this
collaborative yes would you agree yes
and essentially what ends what's ended
up happening is that nurse practitioners
have a better lobbying group than Pas so
26 I think 26 if not more states have
passed independent practice and again I
hate that word um for nurse
practitioners and only six states have
passed it for Pas because it only became
a big initiative um for our very small
state groups to start moving this
forward with in the last about six seven
years so it's only just started and
that's why you only see so many it's not
because the states are oh no this is bad
it's because it just started and we
literally like our group for the new
hire soci of Pas we have 10 Pas on the
board so we all volunteer we a lot of us
have multiple jobs um and it is
schizophrenic because yes many states
are different but they're all moving
towards the same thing and they all
should um but it's just Pas are a little
slower because we have less money and
lobbying power than the nurses do ENT
thank you Mr chair um to continue on the
malpractice and
affordability if I remember well when
Pas initially started it was more cost
effective to provide physician services
at a lower cost because the education
was less all that and by making it you
know carry your own insurance
malpractice all that would that become
more uh costly for PAs to practice and
that in turn change the availability um
no because we we already carry our own
malpractice so that's already happening
in order for us to practice we've always
had to carry our own malpractice it's
just this if they take this away we no
longer have to pay cover the physician
as well so if anything it actually might
lessen it and there was also and thank
you so much for bringing this up there
was a a good article that was just um
put in the apologize let me the medic
out practice payment reports for
physician assistance and it actually was
looking at the states that are removing
barriers for PA practice so moving to
collaboration and autonomous practice
and this was posted in the uh Federation
of State Medical boards or the Journal
of medical regulation and it showed that
there was no increase in payouts for
removing you know going more to
autonomous practice for Pas or NPS can
you send the uh committee email the
email the committee a absolutely copy of
it and if you have paper ones I do I
have it right here great happy to give
it to you I'm sor did that answer your
question yes okay thank you representer
Schmidt thank thank you Mr chairman
so um I I'm almost 86 years old I I had
a quadruple bypass operation about 15
years ago and the first person I saw
after I came out of the anesthesia was
uh
PA I think that was my first interaction
with a PA 15 or 16 years ago also had a
kidney
stone I'm sitting in the emergency room
in at went with Douglas there's a sign
on the wall it says you may request to
see a physician at any time I'm going
like what the hell am I in here for if
I'm not going to be seeing a doctor so a
few minutes later in comes somebody who
looked like a doctor to me he got the
diagnosis 100% correct uh everything he
said was exactly right and the way that
I was treated it was a I had a CAT scan
that didn't show the
stone they didn't do MRIs on the weekend
in those days so I was kept overnight
and the next morning Monday morning they
did an MRI and saw the stone okay so I
got the perfect treatment from from the
the the
NP who was the did the kidney
stone the the the quadruple bypass I was
seen by a PA not by my operator uh and
so forth on a quadruple bypass you think
that they want to have first class
medical treatment right so for me my
experience has been that these people
know what they're doing and both one of
them was the the PA was at Portsmouth
Regional the NP was at with Douglas okay
but the point is they were both hired by
high class well rep reputable Hospital
so for me the treatment seems to be
exactly the same that I'm being seen by
competently trained individuals so I'm I
tend to see Pas as equal to doctors NPS
as equal to doctors depending on what
they're doing so your testimony has been
very enlightening to me in terms of what
the Practical reality is but the
question is uh because in many cases the
doctors are also specializing they're
they're having you seen by somebody
who's a specialist in that area and
you're not all doing
everything so can you comment on uh that
aspect because to the degree that you're
do that you have more
training uh and the the only real
difference is that you got this tether
as Dave quasi says okay if that's the
only difference
seems to me like we ought to get rid of
that difference but can you comment on
some of the aspects that I've raised not
my no absolutely and I think one to to
answer your question a good thing to
point out here Pas a lot are in the
surgical Specialties because it's the
one place that The NPS haven't taken
over and haven't pushed us out of um and
again I love NPS and this is not I don't
want this turn into an NP War because
it's not the case but when you're in a
surgical sub specialty um you're always
going to have a physician there's going
to be Pas in the operating room alone
doing these things you're always going
to have the physician in those
Specialties but yes it's merely just
removing that piece of paper I pay
$1,000 a month for my collaboration
agreement for a doct that I've never met
and he'll never be in my practice and
he's not the person I ask questions I
ask my colleagues I ask the person that
trained me for injectables I talk to her
if I have questions I talk to other NPS
that or PAs or docs whoever it may be
like for my lasers and whatnot if I have
questions or always reaching out we
always collaborate we always do that
nobody practices independently but
especially in the O their pa will come
see you and I it's kind of bad if the
surgeon didn't come see you after I kind
of I'm sorry for that
um that's possible um but no so like
we're this isn't going to be a sudden
shift where all suddenly Pas are opening
up all their practices because if that
were the case why are there not tons of
NP owned practices all over the place
with no Physicians because that didn't
happen in the last 20 years but Pas and
NPS we work the same we work as part of
the team we all collaborate we don't
need a piece of paper to say that we're
going to ask a question then why anybody
would think that ethically Pas would not
reach out when they have a question when
that question is not asked of any other
provider physician or NP
is quite mind-boggling to me um because
we will do that we will continue to do
that we're not going to suddenly change
how we practice and in the surgery we'll
always have a physician there I mean
we're never practicing alone and I know
one argument too has been brought up
that PA some somehow prescribe more
opiates than other providers but if you
think about the surgical sub um
Specialties the doc does a surgery the
PA is doing the discharge the PA is
writing all the opiates for the patient
posttop so of course our prescriptions
might be a little bit more sometimes
because the doc is never writing them so
that also is another argument that is
invalid um but I did that answer your
question I mean really npsp we all
operate the same as the
team the more you talk about what you
are doing what the NPS are doing and so
forth and what the docs are doing uh the
more we understand and can make a
intelligent decision on this Bill Brown
oh Sor I
apologize thank you Mr chair uh thanks
for taking my question so if this passes
you won't have to pay $1,000 a month
anymore for a collaborative agreement I
would not accurate and it also wouldn't
have to pay them Mal practice for the
doctor that is never providing care in
my clinic
interesting thank you okay um a question
to the the crowd and that is is anyone
here uh who's opposed to 1222 and wants
to
speak okay uh who is it I couldn't see
her we have an opposition in the corner
okay uh once you come up um keep her in
the corner I she was behind represent M
I couldn't see her repli can I hand this
to you or uh hand it out to you how many
copies do you have one bring it here
please
then y I have to oh yeah what why don't
you uh sorry representative uh he has an
exact session to go to so if you have
something to say why don't you come
up oh that's all
okay representative Jess Edwards
Rockingham District 31 I'm one of the
co-sponsors of bill um I as I've
listened to the testimony the two
previous people uh having been around
the physician assistant career now
literally for 50 years because my dad
started the program at the University of
Nebraska Medical Center there's a little
bit of a feeling in the way the tone of
this is going a little bit of an Oliver
Twist thing right like kind of a
pathetic ragam muffin saying please may
I have another and I would just like to
stand up and say the physician assistant
career is a proud and capable and
extremely well-trained and experienced
career they're they're an equivalent
they're not equal they're equivalent to
nurse practitioners nurse practitioners
do not need these collaborative
agreements this is an unnecessary
administrative burden that adds costs
and administrative overhead and I really
would appreciate it if you would
favorably consider this bill and and
with that if there are no questions I'll
go to Ways and Means anyone in the
committee represent MTI briefly because
I know he's got to run I know I know you
have to run um with the physician
assistant this collaborative thing is it
somewhat similar to the medical student
or residency that they have the
attendance overseeing and that doesn't
sever after that residency is done I
mean in doctors that is severed that's
done they become independent in PA that
last a lifetime can does that make sense
um thank you for the question I think
it's a fair question of interest and it
it's getting into the detail that's
important to you but I would just pop
back up and say what this bill is trying
to do it's trying to create an an
equivalence between nurse practitioners
and PAs because they're on the same
professional standard I don't know about
the internship and all those other
agreements but miss Leslie apparently
has an example of her collaborative
agreement I'm sure she would share that
with you okay thank you and uh release
you to ways and
means you're going to try not to spend
your money uh no I thought your job was
to bring it in and finance to spend it
that's right uh you have something
briefly come on
up I I just wanted to remind the
subcommittee uh Representatives Ro
and um Edwards did bring an amendment to
the committee and and I think that is a
that really does a better job of
clarifying the intent of the legislation
so I just wanted to make sure that was
on the record that that that they did
bring that and um that we think makes it
a lot clearer um that was sent it was
sent out to the committee do you have
any extra copies of that amendment I I
have a yeah I if it's okay I have the
the original Bill stapled to the
amendment if that's okay that's fine um
who needs one is it uh
224-0454 H for yeah that's the one
okay okay does anybody who's on the
subcommittee need any other questions
answered before we move what I was gonna
she she said she was just here to answer
questions
yeah yeah so I mean yep no I'll take one
I on M original public hearing one I
just had two
oppositions which was Dr
Nick yeah he was and Eva was
representing the AMA so is any of ever
will answer some of the question Medical
Society
yeah what was that I you know okay I
just have one yeah I remember hearing
that and I we got a letter at least I
think we all got a letter are
from I've got it
here yeah so so I have just quick
question if either one of them are
available
yep good afternoon I'm happy to do my
best I will say uh I love to see how
much support Dave's got today from the
PA friends here we I did have a provider
That was supposed to come with me this
morning to the subcommittee to be able
to answer questions as a provider um but
if it isn't something I can answer I I
can get the committee an answer and I
just want to say too the reason I didn't
feel it was necessary for me to take
even more time of the subcommittee is uh
my the medical society's position has
not changed since we uh submitted Our
Testimony at the public hearing but I
wanted to make myself available here for
questions uh and chairwoman McGuire
requested it so I'm here so much quick
question in terms of the main opposition
from AMA is the
education level and they still need PA
still need the supervision am I correct
so I I don't feel I could speak for the
AMA so the that's the American Medical
Association so in my testimony I
referenced a recent article released by
the AMA going off the top of my head
here so I'll do my best in December of
2023 that quoted um the national
leadership of the accrediting
educational or entity for Pas um that
spoke to the fact that the the
curriculum that that is set forth for
them does not is not catered in a way
that seeks for them to I know we've
heard that this word is uncomfortable
for some people but I'm going to say it
because that was what was quoted for PAs
to independently practice so I was
quoting the AMA in that sense but I can
speak on the H behalf of the medical
society as yes what was submitted in our
testimony and if it's helpful to the
subcommittee for their work today I can
recirculated in an email so you have it
in front of you if you don't have it
physically with you today is that there
are concerns you know we the we as in
the society and its members value the
collaborative team and again I know it's
bit conflicting of what you heard
earlier and what I'm saying now but the
collaborative team that Physicians have
with Pas and NPS and the medical team
that works to provide care in our state
they value it they respect it and I want
to make sure that's very clear to your
question similar to my testimony some of
the biggest concerns is the lack of
Education and Training uh the lack of
oversight that we currently have or the
I shouldn't say oversight I should say
the ability for Pas due to their lack of
educational training internships Etc
residency to consult with a physician um
and I have some examples that after
hearing some of the commentary earlier
that I'll supply to the subcommittee or
or the committee at large whichever the
chairman prefers that speaks to
instances where I know of Physicians who
do in fact collaborate on a consistent
basis with Pas and I'm sorry to hear
that that's not the case for some folks
in the audience today um but yeah did
that answer your question
representative and if not we'll keep
we'll keep working at it follow up for
that so in order for the physician to be
in collaboration collaborative agreement
the Pas are carrying their malpractice
yeah so that is to me does not feel I'll
need to get some clarity on that because
I as a previous speaker said I'm not an
employee of the insurance department and
maybe someone from Department in the
audience could speak more eloquently to
the statute that governs the level of
liability that Physicians and PAs or you
know and and what governs that
collaborative agreement if there's a
floor um I I would need to get more I'm
not an expert on how that would impact
the premiums or the current requirement
and I understand that some folks
previously testified that some choose to
carry their own out of protection for
themselves um but I I'm not an expert on
that I would need to get back to the
committee
so that's the question I'm looking for
um the answered uh M we heard some on
the insurance earlier I don't know if
there's any no it just felt like the
Physicians who are collaborating are
getting paid to be a collaborative
supervisor plus their insurance so the
burden of additional cost is on PA not
on the physician so just doesn't
seem fair that's all
I'm going to insist very briefly because
we got another big Bill repres Schmidt
thank you okay so the question I think
that's before us is not whether there's
collaboration going on I think that's
pretty obvious and it was referenced by
Miss Leslie the question is whether
there's supervision going on uh which
seems to be the case that it's not that
they they're connected by that tether
but uh it's not really they're not being
supervised she say she never sees them
if I can inter for a moment um Senate
Bill 228 which I reviewed before this
explicitly removed the supervision
requirement yeah right so that's I was
exactly going to say that Mr chair I
think Dave my friend Dave czy um
eloquently spoke to the history that
resulted from the passage of Senate Bill
228 uh and yes I think between the
chairman and Dave kzy he answered your
question representative Schmidt that it
is a collaborative model and again I I'm
not denying or or I I completely accept
and receive what some of the testimony
has been this morning that there are
instances where Pas uh feel that they
have been in situations that they did
not have an actual physician
collaborating with them however I I you
know I have data and information from
our providers when I heard this at our
you know in previous conversations and
today that suggested that there are
providers who do collaborate in that way
all right thank you oh represent Brown
I'll try to keep this short Mr Mr chair
thank you so my apologies to the rest of
the subcommittee and to all of you who
probably know more about this than I do
and I wasn't on this committee until
recently
so if you remove
collaboration
agreement let me back up a little
bit if I go to see a PA a physician's
assistant and I'm in in in the office
I'm thinking there is a physician
associated with this person that's
guiding this person or helping them out
if we remove collaboration agreement and
it's worded
differently am I wrong in thinking that
now should that not be called a
physician assistant or am I just there
so they're no they're if they're
autonomous they don't have a physician
assisting them or because that it is I
guess that's a whole different topic
whether this name is relevant anymore I
I'll do my best to navigate that um
representative I think I I want to
respect the comments that were shared
this morning that there people have had
experiences where they did not have a
physician to collaborate with but there
are instances I'd like to make a
correction okay that was not what was
stated okay what was stated was that the
physician who signed their collaboration
agreement they did not interact with but
they regularly collaborated with other
members of the medical team including
Physicians and those are two very
different things thank you for the
correction so as far as when there's a
agreements with Pas and the physician is
supposed to be their Chief collaborator
I know of instances where that does take
place um and it does take place so you
know as far as the title I don't feel
like I would be the person to decide
whether or not physician assistant is
still relevant I'm of the mind that that
reflects the current relationship that
exists all right thank you yeah all set
um so what I'd like to do uh if people
in the uh subcommittee are comfortable
with it would be moved to um
no well no we don't do that this not a
public hearing we don't have to do that
uh no to uh I I'd like a motion this is
for the
amendment
yeah I move that we that the um
subcommittee vote ought to pass on
Amendment 0454 H yep okay and do have a
second second uh Bailey all
right all right do we need any
discussion before voting on the
Amendments don't see any all right um
all in favor I anyone opposed okay thank
you and then another motion I I move
that we ought to pass um House Bill
1222 amended a and with Amendment amend
I want to get that one right I was
waiting
okay so that's another
second okay may all in
favor can can I ask put a quick question
on okay um I'm just concerned that we do
not create a rift between the physician
and the physician assistant if there
going to a rift
um that I I think we have evidence that
they do tend to work together this is
specifically whether somebody has to
sign the collaboration agreement and I
would hope they would they would behave
professionally and continue
collaborating as they have separate from
the whole collaboration agreement issue
because the only two Mr chair the only
two opposition was American Medical
Association and one of the Physicians so
they are the collaborators and they are
the team members those are the organiz I
you know anyway
right okay uh anything else any other
discussion okay all in favor on the
motion is um ought to pass with uh with
Amendment on HP 1221 22 22 thank you um
all in favor I I anyone opposed I I
oppose for this particular reason I
didn't get my clarification in terms of
who's getting the Li
why is that and that was answer um can
we get a we'll we'll uh say we can hold
off on the vote and see if we can get an
answer to your issue we not to be quite
as formal in here as the exact
session all right thank you for the
Indulgence Mr chair and thank you for
the question uh in terms of liability I
want to make one important Point as part
of Senate Bill 228 Pas became the only
provider in New Hampshire that is is by
law required to carry malpractice
insurance no other provider is required
by law to carry malpractice insurance
including The NPS and this is about NPS
and PAs and parity there it's not about
parity between docs and PAs so I I so
that I'm not sure why we're you know
frankly it's a it's not a doc
conversation um the the instance I think
that you're referencing uh
representative
is Miss Leslie for example because of
while she's employed she has her own
practice she has to carry as the
condition of this physician car signing
that collaboration agreement that piece
of paper that's the tether it's the
signature on the piece of paper um she
has to carry
his he said he or she I don't know if I
could clear sorry I just let me
interrupt briefly so as I understood it
and you can tell me if this is right or
not that although Senate Bill
228 removed that official liability the
insurance companies still May or or
whoever gets sued in the courts may see
a liability and so in effect the PA
still have to cover some liability for
their collaborative uh MD even though
that wasn't the legislator's intent yes
but if I may Mr chair y in the instance
with Miss Lesley with her own business
she as a condition of that doctor
signing the collaboration agreement asks
her to pick up any additional
malpractice
cost most of the time we're talking
about Pas who are employees as are the
as are the Physicians so they're
employed by Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center as an example I I would the PA
doesn't have to cover the cost of that
doc who's employed by Dartmouth
Hitchcock Medical Center unless unless
there's folks behind me who I'm wrong
that's just that's just added cost to
the employer in that instance so that PA
covering that cost is only when the PA
owns their own business otherwise that's
a a cost borne by the
employer okay can I rephrase this
question AB will this will this bill
remove that requirement for the Pas
because I feel it's not fair for the PA
to carry the doctor's uh malpractice
also so that is my question will this
clear them thank you for the question
the short answer is yes it will clear
them of that because there will no
longer be the need for that signature
that legal tether nothing else will
change Pas aren't looking to do anything
more it's just removing that signature
on that document representative Brown uh
thank you Mr chair so to to be clear if
I'm understanding a doctor has to carry
malpractice if they decide to be a
uh liability insurance if they decide to
have a collaborative agreement that's in
addition so if if someone out there says
I have to pay for the doctor's liability
they're not paying for that doctor's
entire malpractice insurance no just for
the portion I I think for for simpli I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
representative for Simplicity sake it's
almost like you're paying for a rider
thank
you okay that will change my vote uh Mr
chair if that is going to be removed the
burden is removed for Pas I would vote
for I'll just quickly uh so everyone in
favor I I anyone opposed okay thank you
5 to
Zer yeah that's he's not he's not
declining to
vote so I'm uh closing the subcommittee
work session on House Bill 10
1222 thank you to everyone who came here
for
that and then um we're going to move on
to actually let me get a little
organized
here
wonderful all right just uh trying to
get a little organized and then we
will get
there and I have to get my
other slash folder out
yes and now that's closed in full
disclosure two of my sisters are Pas
although not in New
Hampshire and three are our
ends one at one point I was considering
shifting my career to go to PA because
medical field was going to med school
was too long I do have eight
sisters younger all right
okay I'm going to open the subcommittee
work session on House Bill
1408 um what I'd like to
do is um have director Courtney come up
I have some
basically um technical questions and if
anybody else has some as well and then
we'll move on to um other
people who are here so director cour y
Mr chair can I just take a five minutes
all right well how about if we recess
for 5 minutes till 5 after the
hour because we got all of 10 minutes
from the end of the prior Hearing in the
start of this
so and I'll get up and stretch my knees
yeah
question on House Bill
1408 and actually before I get into
anything else is there anybody on the
subcommittee with some thoughts on this
bill
representative gold thank you Mr chair I
do I've given a lot of thought to this
and there are parts and pieces of this
bill that dovetail with a couple of
other bills this subcommittee has and
another bill
that I'm really feeling strongly like
there's still enough there's some good
stuff in here and there's some stuff
that needs to come out of here for sure
and so I would like to propose that we
do interim study on this bill so that it
gives an opportunity for more time and
to coordinate this with the other bills
that have related topics would you like
to make that in the form of motion that
we can have I Mo interm study on House
Bill
1408 I second it okay h on all right
well we'll have discussion yep
uh uh representative um Brown thank you
Mr chairman um
uh would it is would it be would it work
to
just uh postpone this and keep working
on it a little more to see if it
dovetails with those other bills because
interim study is going to kick it down
the road so here's the scheduling
problem with that okay
um we have I haven't got the final list
um just a little bit on for the
subcommittee on scheduling
so um uh chair Maguire wants to exact
all of the remaining um Edna house
builds on the 13th of
March if not
before because we're coming up you know
we're going to be coming up on the
crossover deadline and we don't want to
go down to the last
minute um I and others are going to be
out of town all of next week which means
we will
have the week of let me my calendar out
here yeah so we the week the week
starting the 4th I'm not going to be
back in town until the
um so we have that week except there's a
not a reasonable there's some chance
there's probably not going to be a
session on Thursday the 7th but we don't
know that I actually asked the deputy
speaker at the last session and he said
he couldn't guarantee we
wouldn't
um and we have a number of other bills
still to
do and then even if we get into the next
week there's Monday and Tuesday before
the 13th but if we run it down till
Tuesday and we need an amendment that's
going to get
tight so I think the answer is we really
don't have
time to do further work on the bill this
legislative session and partly that's
because we've had a number of other huge
bills that took a ton of work
representative gold and I and I would
just say that I think this committee's
done a lot of good work on these bills
certainly on what is it 1676 and the
same would be true here if we were to
slug through it I just think time isn't
working for us and that the good work
we've done should be preserved by
kicking it down the road as one term but
also allowing ourselves the time it will
take in the future to address it for you
and and just my these are my thoughts um
on this is that the um in the analysis
section the second part that merg merges
um all the mental health related boards
I that's a big complicated issue maybe
it makes sense to merge some but not all
of them and the problem is um we just
don't have the time to do a good job of
that I don't believe okay so there's Mr
chair yeah I represent MTI yeah thank
you Mr chair I know I'm far in your
Outfield you can join us you joined us
up here it's okay I'm too lazy to carry
my whole baggage here to up there so uh
but I think yeah come on let's let's be
polite yeah uh so
I um identify with your sentiment
especially the second one merger of
mental health practices there's so many
changes so and it's a high critical need
if you don't do a good job and botch it
up you're going to make the situation
even wor we could make it worse maybe we
can make it better but maybe we to make
it better we'd have
to I'm almost certainly we'd have to
change it because I'm not sure they
putting all them make sense so given all
those things things and the time
constraint and so many different things
I think it would be less rushed if he
postpone it and give it a study
committee and give it to due diligence I
agree and so on the first one Architects
and Landscape Architects I mean I'm
whether that makes sense or not I'm not
sure that makes sense um you mean to
join them I mean you know may maybe
making Landscape Architects advisory or
something who knows I mean that's
something we could look at doing there's
other things we could do there and then
the rest of them
are uh changes to the membership of a
number of other boards and as we saw in
hb1
1271 um the proposed changes that came
out of the governor's office I think go
along with his goal of having to do less
appointments but I'm not sure they're
all some might be appropriate and we
agreed with some on that but some may
not and we would have to plow through
each one of those individually and I
took a look at them and I don't think
that any of them are Urgent or going to
make some huge Improvement in the short
term so that's kind of my thinking and I
agree any anyone else want to speak
before we vote on motion I totally agree
with your sentiment Mr CH okay anyone
else uh thank you Mr chair will this
throw any kind of a monkey wrench into
opl's plans or is this yeah actually if
uh director in courtne if you can
comment and are any of these I mean I
looked at this I didn't see any case
where we're fixing a conflict like the
um Jackie non gerain Amendment where you
act we've given authority to more than
one place or
something no this bill was not intended
to address conflicts it's mainly to
address structure so it's not going to
impact our ability to operate okay thank
you um represent
Bailey what the what's the timeline and
interim study or what's the effect of
that so so here's interim study is used
traditionally in a number of different
ways um one as was done with my bill
House Bill
1676 it it allows
for some us to do something else with
the idea so for example as as uh
represent groa graciely suggested we
could do although I think she's thinking
about doing something after this session
but you know we could but we could have
let's say um added an amendment to some
other Bill if we wanted to or you know
non-main Amendment or the Senate could
do something but if we ited it they
couldn't
um the you know the other way it's used
is kind of a polite kill we're not you
know say you're not going to study it
but whatever we don't want to quite we
don't feel that we want to say we hate
the idea uh but the other one actually
is where we really study it and I mean
one example was while I was on
Edna um I ended up chairing a interim
study subcommittee on the um on the very
um
high-profile uh issue of grease traps
but it turns it turns out that we
actually managed to get agreement
between uh the dees and the building
code review board where they work
together and came up with a solution to
the problem that didn't need future
legislation they did some rule changing
training of their staff and you know
something really good was done with an
interim study and that can happen too or
interim study like in this one the
interim study might look at it and and
come up with a new bill that has some
elements maybe of this or maybe you know
other things so anyway that's the way
them
studies yeah IM not to right and and if
I haven't looked at all the Senate
licensing bills but if the senate had
some pieces of this if we ited it that
could stand in the way of those so I was
just going to ask Mr chair if the um
answer in your previous was the solution
in your previous committee on grease
traps an anti-g greasing solution
solution
anti uh it was to expand the options on
the type of grease traps and the size
and exceptions process I was just
teasing and I've been known to play
straight
man yeah I was I was impressed um U
representative Brown so to follow up on
res representative Bailey's question and
to translate what you said this could go
through till oh you asked about
thetically well in effect I mean this
bill would itself would not move forward
so uh to do anything else in this
somebody would have to put in a bill and
during the filing period in the
fall and that could be you know one of
the things inim studies can do is they
get together and they can rem recommend
future legislation and then somebody
typically a member of the subcommittee
but doesn't have to can submit that as
an LSR in the fall and move forward with
that bill that's how it works they can
do anyway recommended not correct
correct but interim study I mean it says
we and actually what happen we do want
to work on this that's the idea and and
presumably you know uh uh chair Maguire
will put together a subcommittee to do
it you know she'll ask if people are
interested somebody will chair it and
then they can meet um and come up with
something excuse me anybody wants to
work on it work you should put your mic
on because we are on oh that's true if
you want to speak that's you know we're
we're still I haven't closed it yet so
um and this is a public meeting so
representative Bailey thank you so one
of the options would be the three
disparate Parts could be broken into
three disparate abely absolutely future
legislation doesn't mean one bill and so
the success of two are not manacled to
the third that's true that's true all
right um if we can move on move to vote
the motion is interim study on House
Bill
1408 um all in favor I I anyone
opposed hearing none that's five to zero
and that's what we'll recommend to the
ful Edna given that I'm closing the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
1408 um a little bit more on scheduling
to the
subcommittee um I've gotten input on
availability uh certainly just before
everybody leaves I want you all to know
that um I'm aware of any tendency there
might for people to feel like this is a
concern that will prolong the misery of
mental health boards and and that that's
not at all the intention of this and
that I think that you'll find any future
committees working well with the mental
health um boards right I'd like to thank
people for showing up I know it's taken
your time and uh some are you getting
pay to be here but others not and we
really didn't know we were going to vote
that until moments ago wasn't like we
could have gotten wor and you know uh
one thing when I before I ran for State
Rep I come up here and testified on
bills and I always wondered whether it
made a difference and I'll tell you my
experience being on the other side is
that it does because um you know most
bills there's something in there that's
brought up that we had no idea so
appreciate
it okay um so for scheduling I've gotten
input from some people on
availability after
okay if you can do that in the next I
what I it is is I'm going out of town
starting Saturday and before that I need
to send an email to schedule public
hearings on all subcommittee meetings on
all the rest of our bills and so um you
know if you have let me know you're
Avail give to I didn't bring my I don't
need it today I'm not going to send it
out today so if if you can send me an
email that's better because otherwise
I'll lose it forget it or because I'm
going have to sit down and do the we of
it's the week of the 4th but also the
first day or two of the following week
although I'd like to avoid that Tuesday
because that means if we have an
amendment on a bill we'll be up against
we could do we get all us to do a quick
Amendment a reminder that Tuesday is
Town election all right and that
Tuesday's Town election which another
reason not to do that day okay so we
only
have or 11 uh uh 46
[Music]
uh oh Carol told me that um she doesn't
plan on
meeting there might be subcommittee
meetings doesn't plan on a full
committee meeting until the 13th oh so
then that opens up right we might have
session on the 7th so I'll avoid that
456 so 4568 are in theory open and did
you you sent me that I looked okay and
then Monday following if we have to I
have
chpr just send me an email
oh
okay 11 basic
maybe I hope we don't have
yeah I'm pro
pro